nouvelle étape dans la reconstruction de
la cathédrale notre dame de paris après
l'abattage de chaîne dans les forêts de
france cette fois ce sont les scieries
qui participent à la renaissance de
l'édifice pour que sa flèche se dresse à
nouveau en 2024 elle transforme ses
grands arbres en pièces de charpente un
travail bénévole mais pour cette scierie
de me lancer en sologne une fierté celle
d'écrire l'histoire samuel colle à
7 mètres du cube au bois du chêne de 200
ans environ il a poussé tout près d'ici
à quelques kilomètres de me lancer ils
sont trois propriétaires à avoir fourni
19 grumes en tout d'être ont découpé ici
et là c'est très beau et très belles
pièces
[Musique]
ce sens pas à faire à la manoeuvre
donald un des dix employés de la scierie
cette journée commence avec un plaisir
certain une main sur les manettes et le
regard tourné vers l'histoire c'est un
petit peu de fierté quand même
me dire que j'aurais contribue à la
une rénovation
de notre-dame un bois dans ce droit et
sans ne destinée à reconstruire la
flèche de la cathédrale son sommet
culmine à 96 mètres du sol et
nécessitent les plus beaux spécimens
mais quand même en qualité vraiment un
peu au dessus effectivement mais c'est
un moment d'exception donc c'est un
petit peu normal aussi de faire ça ça va
faire une charpente d'une très belle
qualité qui va peut on réduire peut
sécher
avoir un retrait faible la charpente de
la flèche ces 500 tonnes de bois alors
parmi la production des 45 syrie mécène
de france les poutres de mille ans et
représente une paille pour autant ces
deux demi-journées de bénévolat ont ici
une valeur inestimable
chaque opérateur entre guillemets tous
une une partie de la charpente de notre
dame et j'ai envie de dire que dans
quelques années quand elle sera
reconstruit bas ils pourront dire ben
moi j'ai touché moi j'ai j'ai participé
moi j'ai fait prochaine étape entreposez
avant l'assemblage à paris prévue début
2010 23 pour une ouverture de notre dame
selon le calendrier officiel en avril